the biggest bartending competition in
the country and one of us is gonna go on
to win the whole thing's a dream come
true you could have gone a little better
totally
judges don't say that see it was now we
go have a drink and wait until the top
ten are nouns I'm gonna have a little
fun tonight not too much you know in
hopes that I make it to the top ten
because you got to be up at 8:30 in the
morning I don't know I'm gonna be like
kicked out of Las Vegas for that I
haven't talked to my wife gap but I'm
gonna wait and so I know the result so
I'm gonna give her a call
I have never done a competition before
let alone one of the biggest
competitions there are pronouncing the
top ten and then they're doing an
interview with me right after the judges
we're like okay we really want to
interview you we really want to
interview you I actually had the
microphone in my hand and someone came
up and gave them the list for the top
ten they're like okay we're gonna
announce the top ten will interview you
after because I tell my friends Oh guys
they want to interview me after I was
like I think that's it's gonna be a good
thing right we had to listen we need
absolute silence the emcee gets on calls
everybody up to the front of the stage
when they started I I was trying to
ignore the pressure but you want your
name to be announced
I'm one of fifty now but if my head I'm
I'm already in the top ten I went from
just having a good time and chill to
okay this is a why I came here Frank
Fontaine so they start naming names I
don't want to be like the Oscars
sourpuss if you don't win so I'm just
trying to have a smile on my face and be
correct I definitely want to win I'd
like to think that I'm in the caliber
that I can make it to the top I really
wish that my parents could be here
especially my mom that wish she could be
here to see this like I just have to
make it to the finals and then I think
that she will be super proud of me
he's got money you got someone else's
name and then it's like okay does it
have a job to do tomorrow I gots a six
and my name wasn't mentioned and what
was going through my hat
say my name there was two people left I
was like okay I'm going to the pool
tomorrow winning the competition would
definitely help my wife and I I mean
possibly is their endless like oh did he
just say Shawn Johnson
let's give it up for the
everybody was ready to party ready to
have fun
so next I guess we just chill out have a
few drinks actually go out tonight and
experience Vegas as it should be
tomorrow I was definitely a little bit
let down that I didn't make the top sad
because you build everything up in your
mind but at the same time I was like
super proud to see Shaun and Carly go up
so I was very excited that they were a
part of it and then some other really
nice people I had met hi how's it going
they announced the top ten and I didn't
make it I'm still proud that I was able
to you know get that fire thanks I mean
just because you didn't win this doesn't
mean that I'm gonna stop wanting to have
you know our own business this would
have been a good catalyst to get it up
and going a lot sooner but who knows
what's gonna happen tomorrow alright I
love you I'll talk to you later I want
to celebrate a little bit I want to soak
it in I want to feel it and then get to
work tomorrow
I'm literally competing against the best
bartenders in this country well I'm
gonna work harder now you know like I'm
gonna make sure that everything is on
point
I haven't actually told my parents yet
that I want it's almost like
i-told-you-so moment
kind of that i-told-you-so kids it's
gonna be like this is an amazing thing
that I just accomplished and you should
be proud of me excited see what happened
my phone's off nice I was not prepared i
bombed it a challenge just got even
bigger gotta step up my game if I'm that
much closer I gotta work that much
harder
nine of the best bartenders in this
country all of the peppercorns and the
muddling and the slicing dicing
everything this is an art and it's a
crash and we're chefs in our own right
hundreds I just don't think it
represents what this pamphlet was about
I had a little pregame jitters I'm super
nervous super anxious ready to find out
the winner the preparation that's not I
have no idea how things are gonna shake
out
please will you announce the 2013 most
imaginative bartender